après le portier du crime de la
journaliste informé au sol
la politique d'immigration des lignes sera
sur l'annonce sociale ou le doute
préjudiciable marqué par un peu de moi
fils de l'ego et l'expression non parce que le
délégation de motions 512
ancien président à vie et laisser un
Empreinte Tijuana de l'arc de la fonction
americana del camping de mexico annoncé
celui qui s'épuise après la famille du
rapports de détermination seulement
dit quand les gens s'expriment
la mesure est exceptionnelle
divulgation avec prestige et la balle
réduction lo 2020 et alex wei lmt
[Musique]
dans
[des rires]
grand espagnol
Oui biensur
d
ou non
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
il n'y avait pas
Non
[Musique]
parler de la campagne burga
ce serait mieux
physiquement
dpa de Lisbonne
la demande de ligne a augmenté
mais pas d'eau
[Musique]
la vie à Miami
augmenter les pauses liberbank de ces
centres californiens
la station inai ma vie
sur le mur
ma vie
il m'a regardé crick bucks
la fin de l'homme libre à tijuana
[Musique]
peau seulement
et
déjà
comme à Tijuana dans le sens de
tracas sportifs qui sont avec la région
États
[Applaudissements]
n'importe qui en anglais figure el ayni
[Musique]
côté et pics des taupes d'intérêt
Le Mexique dans le monde des compétences pour la vie la
semaine
[Musique]
Ouais
Ils m'ont menotté derrière le dos et
ils ont une voiture
[Musique]
eh bien ne posez pas de questions
en moins de 30 minutes ils m'ont déjà eu
pris pour vous 41
[Musique]
d
ou non
J'ai vécu 31 ans aux USA
[Musique]
tout ce qui avait construit tout ce qui
était parti du jour au lendemain
Oh
il y a une mission
à un jour n'hésite pas
si ça va tout seul
[Musique]
Eh bien, quand tu étais ici, je pouvais
éliminer
soit parce que les enfants m'ont emmené
aussi
[Musique]
Eh bien, il a essayé
puisque je veux déjà revenir mais
quand on s'enfuit mais il n'est pas là
parce qu'ils vont pleurer oui non
d'accord
moi aussi j'ai hâte de les voir
je veux les voir
ne pleure pas maman
Ne pleure pas s'il te plaît
ensuite
carmen sera moi
titulaire plus
voici les moyens de la granca
je l'écris
[Musique]
Aux États-Unis, j'avais mon entreprise, je travaillais
J'ai travaillé dur pour que mes enfants
ils réussiront à obtenir leur université
[Musique]
et soudain tu te retrouves dans un autre
lieu
seul
[Musique]
Mon crime est d'être entré
sans papiers
Je n'ai jamais eu de problèmes avec la police
rien
tout était un travail acharné
[Musique]
Je pense que si je dois revenir
et je sais que la situation actuelle peut être
voir un réversible
mais je sais aussi qu'un miracle peut
changer
Siestes
et puis prends ça oui
suis
les hivers
d'accord
par sweeney miss
et non
[Musique]
dans le sexe
[Applaudissements]
soit
dans
Oops
il
tri tri bien dans
marche générale
Yo
[Musique]
et puis dire que je suis blanc
pop-corn pourquoi pas
j'ai fait mon
mes choses ont fait de mauvaises choses que j'ai vendues
médicament
mais je venais de là
depuis que j'ai 3 ans, la famille est téléchargée
supplémentaire dans le pays
[Musique]
Yo
h
bien
hoyos de castro plus d'émotions que
ne parle rien des mois avec toi garde le pouvoir
à absorber ce soir sont des instructions
allez
[Musique]
au centre
je veux crier pleurer
envie de sortir ce courage que j'ai
toujours sourire même si à l'intérieur
tu meurs
être un clown
[Musique]
le seul qui m'a vu en tout
est la femme émeraude est celle qui m'a
vu tout le bien le mal
avec seulement
chaos
tu vas bien et amuse toi bébé
à l'esprit mais tu sais
corps de te regarder
comme tu dis
notre nation
et les sains
mais pas fermer autant
[Musique]
Yo
il en a un
ces lignes
m'empêche d'embrasser ma femme
ligne de chemin
[Musique]
soutenons rifai
Sanz à Rouzier
et
Déjà là
[Musique]
son
commande
[Musique]
ciel
C'est plus
Plus fort que les fils de terrain dans le Web
et billy teis 'mon chemin' étranger
retourner au travail
J'avais la caméra de la cage
[Musique]
avant
bon
[Musique]
quand
et le Viêt Nam
mon
Austin
[Musique]
Oh
mon professeur agustín del este
Prairie
[Musique]
mais c'est quand même bien
manger en forme de flocon
admission
bien quand il
je t'entendrai
[Musique]
Gerlo
danaher dieu est amour
[Musique]
Bernstein a dit
mais que veut quelqu'un
lumière normale
Oh
et
comment ça va
après
et
Aujourd'hui je reviens
Ce n'est pas comme je le voulais
le transport que je
[Musique]
Après trois mois à Tijuana pendant
la première fois qu'ils sont venus me rendre visite
filles
[Musique]
droite
vous ne pourrez pas la remorque ne sera pas
arrête tu dois bouger bouger bouger
par là
[Musique]
et
Donc
est
est que
[Musique]
Yo
La nuit dernière, je n'ai pas pu dormir à cause de la chaleur et
puis mirage fosses partout
a
Allez je vais te montrer la salle de bain
Regarder
voici la salle de bain mais comme il n'y en a pas
de l'eau tu dois verser de l'eau d'ici
on puise aussi de l'eau
en chantant
imaginez vivre ici
Ouais
[Musique]
Eh bien, oui, j'en ai marre de faire des cigares
des plats qu'ils ne font plus j'y vais
à faire
le rapide
et ils vous disent les titres d'amd et quoique
tu leur dis tu me donnes je leur dis quelle balle
Vous êtes dans un autre pays et vous ne pouvez pas
retourner
ils sont petits ils ne comprennent pas et
J'ai l'impression que les jours ne devraient plus
savoir
imaginez qu'ils vont grandir et que je ne vais pas
regarder
Ce est à dire
explorer toute notre vie très chère et
12 livraison aux États-Unis et nous nous sentons comme
que maintenant ils nous donnent un mois pour le duvet
après tant d'années de travail
sacrifice pour envoyer nos frères
à l'armée et tout ça pour
l'enlever, c'est que les États-Unis sont un pays qui
ouvert les portes je le dis pour moi
parce qu'il a eu l'occasion d'avoir mon
entreprise d'avoir une maison de donner à
vous un autre niveau d'éducation
à un niveau d'enseignement supérieur
ceux qui ne sont pas des criminels comme vous
ils font le pays et c'est une injustice
[Musique]
donc tu as déjà fait
où ils ont fait une interview dans
Anglais
Eh bien, c'est un centre d'appels où ils décrochent
appels provenant des états-unis d'entreprises
des États-Unis mais pas en salaires, très peu et
alors je réaliserai que je serai
assister
Entreprises américaines si vous n'êtes pas aux États-Unis comme celui-ci
il me semble que c'est beaucoup
un sac triste tristesse et mélancolie
exactement
[Musique]
amen
quand vous êtes dans les applications de combat de fleurs
retour
et
et ça commence à devenir cool ils ont dit
la science
ici je le passe je suis assis là dans le
petite chaise et je commence à regarder là-bas
wow c'est trop vieux
après une commande vous ne voyez pas pourquoi
parce que c'est plein comme de la fumée
allez ne ressens plus ça
ils deviennent plus petits
[Musique]
il n'y a plus le même
je ne pourrai pas passer
[Musique]
et
et donc une fois
Quoi
pourrait être
et voyez si la prochaine fois vous pouvez créer
les enfants aussi
beaucoup beaucoup
[Musique]
les biographes en ce moment
Yo
[Musique]
et je vais moi-même
pour ne pas
l'amour que je veux oui
il ne voulait pas m'aimer
Yo
je pars vaincu
coeur
[Musique]
parce que mon amour
en outre
[Musique]
onetoone touche 16
heureux et
enfant
En fait
oignon oignon te rend bon
dix
d'accord
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ça ne sent plus
[Musique]
toi ce soir
d'accord
et comme le déversement
vila verra
marcher
pour
Natalia
un musée
[Musique]
est le premier appel l'oesophage
ayoví super ce que nous allons essayer
gardez-le, je sais que je vous demande
plus loin
et quelle nappe sens-tu si tard
la voiture
le moment
oui examen a faire
et
maintenant
les sceaux à nairobi et ces cratères qui
peut être un bon point
événement et vous êtes une loi d'esprit riche
Howard
vous avez besoin de bonnes personnes pour manifester
Richard
Austin me fait démissionner
[Musique]
l'eau du serveur manuel peut être extraite dans
Afrique
[Musique]
depp dans la mesure
à nos frais pour les Rolling Stones
homme pour acheter des marques
et quelqu'un essaie cet uruguay de x
Hommes
de toute façon et ce que je ferai jordi colina la
minorquin
et
[Musique]
et le Mexique
gouvernement et amis officiels
loi vétérinaire d'état de la ligue de football
est walid au mexique
mot au mexique
weiwei avec un mur
ma personne queen factor états et plafond
jr
bon
en avatar pour être
heureux sur le web
m h
d
imaginez la confiance et dans les amériques
attendre des années
à cause de cette autoroute 9
déjà sans couverture déjà michel
pour scandale
et ce Noël
Paris
parle moi de
de mon amour
[Musique]
Non
très grave
en ce
Ils ont aussi Jean 10
En uruguay
Ouais
il
camouflet de moquerie
tu dois donner du football
efe
[Musique]
ici les heures semblent éternelles
Yo
[Musique]
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles nous avons décidé
mettre des caméras à l'intérieur de la maison à san
Diego est pour que ma mère s'occupe de
quand je devais sortir
[Musique]
je peux les voir
je peux les entendre
ils ne me font pas
[Musique]
Liens familiaux c'est ce que je sais
est définitivement en train de perdre
[Musique]
ou est-il déjà perdu
on lui enlève le bouchon
[Musique]
les puits de 32 nouvelles années qui sont
ils ont fait la grimace
et donc
Oui, j'ai déjà mon nez, ma femme
j'ai déjà tout
voyons je vais mettre les gens que nous sommes
[Musique]
mon mari émeraude est ma vie dans
Youtube
Je regarde mes voyages avec elle, je regarde mes
mort avec elle
[Musique]
Nous apprécions
On dirait que la pression a baissé.
croire
parfois
mais
[Musique]
Je n'appartiens pas ici c'est l'enfer
[Applaudissements]
Je ne regarde pas mourir ici
[Musique]
il n'y a pas si longtemps médecin une personne
Combien de temps allez-vous encore vous attendre ?
femme, penses-tu qu'il peut te tenir jusqu'à
revenir
[Musique]
quand mon fils a ri mais à l'intérieur
Je reste léger dans cet esprit, je sais que je
aimer mais
je vais m'attendre je chante
[Musique]
J'ai toujours pris mais quelqu'un m'a dit
prendre plus
[Musique]
mon mari dit que tu en prends trop
au revoir
c'est un
soulagement de la douleur
Ils comprennent le vertige et je ne ressens plus le
tant de solitude
et déjà
et un peu d'oubli
aussi
[Musique]
gérard garcia
le présent discordant est
mon cadeau
[Musique]
clairement les parents que vous me donnez le
La victoire sans frein s'appelle la route et
Now Happening Saint Forming Science
tirso le père
ici il parle d'une entrée d'argent
bientôt
que voulez-vous dans ces
des moments pour que vous puissiez récupérer
qui vient est sa famille
il veut revenir ici un ange lui dit
il revient bien
des questions
tout ce que vous voulez demander
sortait avec des menottes
Bien qu'il
[Musique]
bien
dans le texte le saint et le noir de
combattre la vie
le profil était max
[Musique]
nouvelles dans le temps
aux nations d'asie novation du
geste de vouloir bien revenir de lobería
un autre nitreux ne doit être acheté que pour
voir qui est où ils m'ont donné de nombreux et
il y a trois premiers cours complets en
la
madeleine à higuey
pour cela la tournée des 15 et
il y a des universités
[Musique]
Yo
Je jure devant Dieu
[Musique]
bonne pensée à nous
j'ai passé la nuit
[Musique]
peine à dormir
et
et moi à roger
tu t'en vas
[Musique]
être
mes matins et si tu pars
bon
jusqu'à quand
[Musique]
bien
ce que je vais perdre clairement
[Musique]
certainement pas
canaliser
[Musique]
pas toi
Dans les yeux
[Musique]
audeline
Oui
Quoi
[Musique]
c'est ça
d'accord
[Musique]
eh bien, ce que l'ex obtient
gardien porto
la fête internationale
de
syllabes transmédia
[Musique]